not every Hollywood release can be a
home run but that doesn't make it any
better but you have to sit through a
terrible movie in 2018 these are the
films that perked up our ears a leftist
athlete disappointed on release these
are the worst movies of the summer
action points on paper action points
seem like surefire comedy gold the film
is based on the infamously dangerous T
reel action park and features johnny
Knoxville and his pals putting
themselves in harm's way for our
entertainment action park this place New
Jersey it is the most dangerous theme
park of all time hands down it seemed
like it will be full of insane stunts
but action point arrived in theaters
only to fall right on his face amazingly
many critics found action points not
insane enough Reno news and review
critic Bob grim who survived the actual
action park as a child called it
basically an insult to the legend of
action park or death Park as we like to
call it God a a passion project for
starred John Travolta the biopic godly
arrived after cycling through producers
and directors at an alarming rate its
release date was pushed back several
times as a result and the when it
finally landed in theaters all that
discord was visible right there on the
screen many critics praised Travolta's
committed performance even though it was
delivered in the service of a borderline
incoherent film The New York Times Glen
Kenny concurred saying that the long
gestating crime drama gaudy is a dismal
mess comes as no surprise what this
shock is just how multifaceted a dismal
mess it is the happy time murders
starring Melissa McCarthy as a human
police detective in a world where people
coexist with sentient puppets the happy
time murders had all the makings of a
raunchy edgy love fest unfortunately the
film arrived without any of the laughs
the production is the first from Henson
alternative an adult-themed offshoot of
the late Jim Henson's studio and was
helmed by a son Brian both facts has
seemed to depress the majority of
critics bloody disgusting Scott Weinberg
summed it up as ugly mean-spirited and
aggressively redundant and his fellow
critics seem to agree gringo if this is
your first time hearing of the action
comedy flick a gringo you're not alone
the film flopped spectacularly and why
police grossing only about 11 million
dollars worldwide despite an insanely
flesh cast featuring David Oh yellow Oh
Charlize Theron's and Amanda Seyfried
the story follows a mild-mannered
American who goes wild on a trip south
of the border but the film failed to
make an impact on audiences and critics
alike
bowling stones David fear called it a
romp that's keen on going nowhere most
of the critical venom was reserved for
its unfunny contrived a mess of a
screenplay
on which the film's amazing cast was
apparently completely wasted Slender Man
fans could be forgiven for approaching
Slender Man with a healthy amount of
trepidation plot details have been kept
tightly under wraps tur in the film's
production and the entire endeavor
wasn't helped by the real-life tragic
case of a young girl who was stabbed
nearly to death but when the film hit
theaters it became clear why we hadn't
heard much about the plots there wasn't
much of one to speak off critics
absolutely flogged a picture for its
paper-thin story and lack of any genuine
scares with John 2:4 of The Hollywood
Reporter calling it one of the most
boring wide-release horror flicks of
recent years and it's hard to disagree
kin the debut feature of twin brothers
Jonathan and Josh Baker kin sports an
interesting sci-fi premise a teenager
and his recently paroled older brother
find the powerful futuristic weapon more
tangling with a local drug lord kim
ashes up elements of road movies family
adventures and futuristic thrillers but
that wide net of influences is the
problem
critics almost universally complained
about the film's wildly uneven tone the
film also failed to hit the sweet spot
either as a sci-fi action movie or as a
family drama as Jake Coyle of The
Associated Press put it given the film's
title and at the filmmakers are
themselves twins you would expect a
brother relationship at the heart of the
movie to be something more than it is
game over man a source of comedic spin
on die hard a game over man features
workaholics star Blake Anderson on dis
home and Adam Devine as regular Joe's
forced to fight back against terrorists
unfortunately the film is packed of
unnecessary wantonness and vulgarity far
more often than that premise would seem
to justify
Charles romesco of the Guardian had one
of the hardest criticisms for the film
writing that with us an explicable
combination of phallic revulsion
fascination and revulsion at its own
fascination this wretched film hates
itself more than we have occurred the
darkest minds director Jennifer yuh
Nelson looks set to launch a lucrative
new franchise with the darkest minds but
the film wasn't good enough for one
movie let alone sequels by a large
critics found that Minds simply wasn't
original enough it's extreme derivative
nurse wasn't helped by a confusing
script that rushed through important
plot points and even the photography was
called out for being drab and visually
unappealing
Dana Schwartz of Entertainment Weekly
called the darkest minds a mad libs
version of a dystopian y-a adaptation
done by someone who saw half of an x-men
movie on TV once with no death and no
new ideas and no point life of the
partay following a recently divorced
middle-aged woman that goes back to
college life of the party seemed like
the perfect setup for some bravura
Melissa McCarthy set pieces McCarthy and
husband Ben Falcone who co-wrote the
picture inexplicably failed to provide
the comedy fuel to make the star vehicle
run critics lambasted the film and poor
script with the Atlantic's Christopher
or writing that the film doesn't live up
to either of the nouns in its title
[Music]